hey yo blue face baby all right it's me
and rock we here with bootleg Kev
hey name is that bro
we're rolling bootleg cat podcast
special guest here
my friend blueface and his lady yeah all
right Christian rock
welcome good to see you guys in good
spirits
all right
boys
I mean it's kind of his thing right no
yeah
uh
so you guys are are together correct we
are together you guys I feel like we
always see when you guys
all right
[Music]
see here we go again
what I'm just trying to keep up what's
going on with y'all that has yeah to
answer the questions he said yeah all
right that's why I don't want to do
anything
technically an answer
technically yes that's my answer for
every question you got so what are we
talking about now you want to be like me
so bad no it's just what are we doing
catchphrase well
good to see you guys question how are
you doing
great you're doing good
how are you dealing with um all the like
kind of like
Newfound stardom because you are kind of
like
every other day viral as hell you know
what I'm saying your music career is
taking off your TV star now how do you
deal with all the kind of being the
the uh
I guess between the two of y'all you
might somebody say you more popping than
blue now
hell yeah
I don't know I don't care
you don't care no it's cool yeah that's
it is it hard to deal with like
everybody in y'all's business all the
time though
that's whatever
what put them all up in the [__]
business
what could you be capping front and all
types of [__] so
hmm
well at least you guys I mean look it's
good to see you guys back together you
know
if only for a while there uh you know
Super Bowl weekend seemed kind of rough
for y'all
right it was a rough week for me for
sure
you were getting bags I'm sure Super
Bowl week I saw you like at every party
in Arizona
for free he came to my party
it was a good time you were like that I
better have fun bias on it I work every
weekend so when we cannot get off yeah
what about time super weekend
the game was lit
how's the pregnancy going
cool good question yeah
why are you trying to say good question
what are y'all trying to go viral for
I'm
I can turn up like what's that I'm not
drinking so you're not drinking anymore
because of the baby
still down to throw the paws though
yeah you ain't drinking but you fight me
not that far along
how are you dealing with uh with the
pregnancy though that's like a big uh
there's a lot going on in your body I'm
sure
um
I'm excited I don't know I have nothing
bad about it the same
when are we getting the uh the
ultrasound so we know the baby sex or
you're going to kind of just let it let
it ride and just be surprised when it
happens no I was we were filming uh the
season two of crazy in love so that's
going to be on there we're going to do
this whole oh so that's a part of the
new season yeah shout out to the Zeus
Network yeah
so let's
that's the catch but other than that
help me understand like y'all two
obviously we see a lot of dysfunction
how much of the dysfunction is for
entertainment purposes and how much of
it is like because you guys are pretty
dysfunctional
in terms of what we see will the
dysfunction just becomes from
like
we do business together and we together
so it's like
y'all don't know half the time which one
is going on right and we don't know half
the time which one is going on so it's
like
that's the destruction no it's the fact
that it works yeah yeah no we really
don't give a [__] about what y'all think
but right like when we going through our
things that we don't get what's going on
you know so to her it might seem like
I'm tripping off her taking a picture or
whatnot right right but to me it's more
like I'm on some benefit like it's not a
it's it's not if it's not like a
beneficial look
I I personally don't agree with it well
technically you're are you her manager
yeah yeah like I signed her so she like
so she signed to you as an artist and
she's your lady exactly sure your baby
mama
more complicated so it's like when
people like say like oh she's
complicated and complicated
he was like that's a good thing because
she signed to you yeah true yeah right
you think I I put bring somebody to
Captain and like I don't I want her to
get to where I'm at like so let me
figure so so this is the thing though
right because if we think about her as
an artist because she has music and she
assigned to you wouldn't because I saw
you did get a little you got kind of mad
about her taking a picture with Rick
Ross yeah
and communicating with a little baby on
some big bro [__] as an artist wouldn't
it be so annoying well wouldn't it be
smart for her to network with Rick Ross
and little baby for her career hell no
why not because they're not gonna wait
it's not it's not gonna be real
networking you know what I'm saying it's
gonna be like because if I'm managing an
artist and they can
chop it up with Rick Ross or chop it up
a little baby who's one of the hottest
artists in the world I would encourage
that
not when they're trying to [__] that's
what they're trying different so do you
think they're trying to [__]
he says it I just be like I don't
she she knows she she like to play
around
so like little baby chopping it up with
you calling you big brother his big bro
which you didn't like obviously I saw
the tweets no that was the that was the
throw-off that's not what he was telling
her while he was in front of her type
[__] so when he was in front of you was
it like more like what's good
or was it like hey I see what you're
doing you're killing it yes he was like
that's what I figured right yeah but she
learned she didn't tell you he was like
oh you sexy oh I want you around oh you
got potential come to the studio
what's your number let's look like
cousins
it wasn't that but
right taking everything so loud hey [__]
left you try to water her death murder
put down and okay it's cool if she
networking
there you go if she never gonna it's by
all means it's cool right but once
there's money being talked about and
business that's being exchanged now it's
unprofessional so if a little baby just
invites you to the studio
and you're not there you're you're not
okay with that
oh no I'm okay with that okay I'm okay
with that how about that song yeah but
it better be it better be something
transpiring it better not be like what
if they're just listening to beats and
they're chopping it up about like her
career or whatever whatever and like a
song well then I would have to be there
anything what has to do with her career
I have to be there to speak her best
you know
best interest do you feel like your
relationship your personal relationship
could Cloud your managerial relationship
I don't know because it's almost to the
point where it's like
if I wasn't a rapper that would make
sense right but I am which means all I
gotta do is take care where I go yeah
roll it out just take it all right do
yourself uh show okay do your set so
it's kind of like it doesn't like if I
wasn't a rapper then it'll be like I'm
getting in the way
because
I have nothing to offer her from the
artist's side of things right I'm
blocking her from
somebody else putting her on they said
and some you know what I'm saying so no
I don't think it'll fix you also gotta
understand too like she is on fire right
now so if you're Rick Ross and you see
Christian rock at the Super Bowl you're
gonna be like oh [__] let's let's click
no you're not why not do you think Rick
Ross does that no I actually do think
that because Rick Ross is a pretty like
like mellow dude I feel like he was
probably high as [__] at the Super Bowl
I was like oh [__] you're the girl on
the internet wow being nice that's crazy
if y'all think Rick Ross walk up to
[__] that's famous and say can I get
a picture of you you're high right now
you think that's what Rick Ross does
what do you think
what do you think happened blue
honestly
honestly oh I'm not there so I can't say
what I think this was actually Super
Bowl all I can speak on is what what I
think that they're thinking they never
seen her in person and obviously when
you see a person she's bad as hell so
it's like oh [__] it's her right and
it's like
that's cool but you also like no you
can't just don't be unprofessional buddy
don't go out to her and be like yo I
think we can do business and let's let's
do this and let's do that let's do that
like that's like me walking up to to
what a little baby artist for two days
and I'm like yo bro I think you do a
party she got potential look I got this
much money for you let's let's figure
out how we can keep you around and make
you big little baby's gonna be like bro
what the [__] are you doing this is my
artist like what why would you do you
want to do a song or something great
tell them to contact send the song Make
It professional how about this what if
her networking with little baby equals
eventually her getting a feature from
little baby which would be big for her
career no
I'm just listening because that's not
his character how many females do you
know little baby to do music with
I don't know okay how many famous
rappers do you think little baby has had
sex with
I don't know I don't want to speculate
on another man do you think I don't know
another man's dick you know what I'm
saying [__] his dick we're talking about
I just asked you how many females have
you seen him to do music with I can't
think of many okay why do you think that
is I don't know that's probably not his
thing right
that's fair is she the hottest musical
artist out right now as a female no so
does that make sense to you
yeah yeah it's not rocket science yeah
it's not Rockets So two plus two equals
four disrespected me again who's more
jealous between the two of y'all [__] is
crazy
both of y'all are pretty jealous look
you want to know what's crazy about the
whole situation she came up with this
rule okay what's that I can't work with
any female artists
she came up with this rule did you come
up with this rule
after the fact that something had
happened
it's not the best rule this is a
terrible rule because now
it works
the same thing so what you even talking
to them for if you came up with this
weird-ass rule
y'all gotta get rid of that rule man
tell her you don't like that I got paid
40 000 from a female to do a song she
talking about give it back because he
was that's it
for that weekend I could never he didn't
take me to the session he didn't take me
to the video shoot none of that he was
being weird so he's being weird with the
feature it made me like what that's
that's what what happened we was beefing
you didn't invite me nowhere when you
was doing it right and then he was
making like you doing something way more
important than hanging out with me like
it was weird what does that have to do
with it it's like certain things he do
it gets under my skin shut the [__] up
what I'd like to say it's really good to
see both of y'all without a bottle of
Hennessy around that's great
do you feel like Christian like you guys
were like becoming a little dependent on
the bottle for a while it looks like
everywhere I would see y'all there'd be
a [__] no I just like the bottom you
just like Hennessy yeah a little too
much no I'm not dealing with him no
she's like I need it [__]
yo I saw you linked with glorilla um and
it's funny because uh I'm sure you saw
the viral clip on my podcast yeah she's
pretty cool when we talked about you and
your behavior and she said it was quite
normal it is well can you because there
was a guy from the hood or something
that's why listen Christian I need you
to take me back to when you stole the G
wagon
was it a G wagon he was beefing again
and you you listen what's going through
your mind
did you
didn't you write me you wrote like your
name on the wall in blood yes then leave
him a note like let him know who's got
his car so you're gonna think right but
I'm ignore him so you go to his house
you break it I don't break in the glass
already broken in from the first time so
you get in from the last time you broke
the glass yeah okay
you cut yourself open why is he doing it
no no I just said it sounds crazy
because this is this is no way yeah
y'all know me talking about some so why
are you mad at the picture well you
might do I believe it already went
through [__] World horses wait
wait so listen so you cut yourself open
to write a note
hey call me DJ head again yeah
why do you think will rock you just kind
of ask my [__] for a picture she didn't
do all this to me I
I actually think that like your girl is
a cultural like she's like cultural
Phenom right now so I think Rick rossify
as [__] at the Super Bowl I do think it
is the realm of possibilities for Ross
to be like
oh [__] yeah right I think it's possible
I don't know about the little baby [__]
that seems a little bit more stuff I
would think Ross is more cooler than
that
I think he's cooler than that though
anyway so can we get back to that's not
cool are you taking pictures with [__]
like what the [__] look at females weird
for doing that like oh can I eat it no
it's 20 23 now you gotta let [__] go
this [__] is weird right but now if a
man do it it's not weird
how I don't know I don't think it's
weird oh now you don't know I don't
think it's weird if I met Nicki Minaj
I'd want a photo with her
you're different
it's a different setting no like it's
like an industry type if I'm at the
Super Bowl and we're in a suite and like
I see somebody from my favorite TV show
I'm probably gonna be like oh [__] I
don't think it was like that we honestly
I don't know how do you tell us that
happened did he just walk past was it no
everybody the game is over everybody
coming out their sweets so in that but
in the hallway you have to pass yeah
everybody's just standing there
everybody that's standing there is like
famous or whatever so he was just
walking through
and then he was like oh [__] hey can we
get back to I don't know you cutting
yourself open I'm like that babe I don't
want to talk about this for sure
he's trying to get a picture
he really was like hey can I get a
picture of it that sounds like something
Ross would do he said hey he walked back
like he walked past me then he he was
he was going to go the biggest boss what
that's what happened what the [__] is
you talking about why did you understand
okay he didn't stop
I saw the picture the picture was uh it
was cute it was it was innocent it
wasn't that much it was fine
to me at least but I mean obviously I'm
a different types
I'm a different type of [__] Kev like
you don't see Rihanna in no picture with
nobody like that right if you saw
Rihanna you would you wouldn't get the
photo hell no I'm I'm just it's not me I
don't know I could never see myself like
hey can we get a pick like but that's
what happened that's just strange well a
grown man to do I think you guys need to
get over this like uh jealousy [__]
because both of y'all are popping I
personally go give a [__] your face is
tattooed on her neck it's kind of like
this okay but if somebody's paying so
much close attention to you after a
while you're gonna be like well hold the
[__] up let me start looking at you and
like sizing you up but you also think
that like if your face is tattooed on
her neck twice people understand that
she's with you
obviously the [__] not if they're
walking up talking about yo let's
oh you look good I can't be around and
obviously no no what are you talking
about do you I think that makes them
wanna [__] more Jesus Christ well
she's also pregnant
do you understand why I'm tripping now
okay
does that work better for me now boy
[Applause]
getting out of pregnant [__] girl okay
well
yeah back to what we were talking about
me and Gloria
were talking about you Krishan and I
told her the story about what the day
you took the G-Wagon and did the blood
yeah
I asked you a question
do you guys have each other's hey do you
guys have each other's code to your
phones do you have each other's codes to
the phone
no he just know my code
what the [__] is wrong
you see the shitty grips
that was you okay so the rule is you
have her code she can't have your code
I like that
is that the rule like if she wanted to
code to your phone would you give it to
her you're like nah
what's wrong
what do you mean
you keep laughing that's really good
because he know what he's trying to do
right now what am I doing I'm just
asking honest question answer
you could change your code at any time
right
like my coat today might not be my code
tomorrow because I'm a high profile
rapper and I need to make sure my
Security's on point
I took out no I just no that's what it
is I just don't agree with it then why
are you in my phone
like I told you earlier it's only I only
get one I only get one [__] to care
about that I sleep with every night hey
you care if you feel me almost call me
head again
you got one right yeah my wife yeah I'm
married yes
hey you're not married and you sure
you're gonna be hard on it right yeah
that's just that weird [__] you good
that's unfair
do you guys foresee a future of marriage
between the two of y'all
the answer is I know
can't believe a marriage so no so you
don't believe in marriage because you've
never been married before right no so
it's just something you're just not like
I just don't see the point yeah it
doesn't make yeah I I respect it but I'm
getting married though you're getting
married to somebody
um
will it be hard to find somebody if your
ex's face is tattooed on your neck
I'm just I'm just curious because I feel
like once you get the tattoo it should
be him right it should be
that wouldn't even make sense what
yeah I don't know I don't know what what
we would have for that I don't know but
with all the tattoos that's why I be
confused I'd be like
how are you confused are you gonna get a
Christian tattoo or do you have one no
he's not breaking up like why are you
why are you saying you're breaking up
he's saying shut up he said how you
gonna find somebody
I already found you I'm cool she's
already got it man now she just has to
convince you to walk down the aisle
about the interview man hey shout out to
my bookie man make sure you go to
mybookie.ag NFL season it's over but at
my bookie the opportunities to win
they're not over baby they don't stop
ever all right whether you want to make
some extra or just make the games more
exciting my book is going to give you
the most for your money with their
deposit bonuses now listen if you sign
up right now go to mybookie.ag use that
promo code bootleg you're going to get a
welcome bonus up to a thousand dollars
and on top of that March Madness is on
the way ladies and gentlemen that's
right that college basketball tournament
is coming they're going to give you a
free hundred and fifty thousand dollar
March Madness bracket contest entry
imagine if you win 150 Grand you have to
put no money up crazy you got to go to
mybookie.ag sign up with that promo code
bootleg right now thousand dollar
deposit bonus if you put a thousand and
they will give you another thousand all
right and of course so much to bet on
with my book you could do NCAA okay NBA
NHL UFC boxing what Jay is Jake Paul
gonna win I don't know but you could you
could put some money on Jake Paul I
would all right of course they also got
their weekly online Blackjack
tournaments so much roulette I mean
slots so much with so many Brands to
choose from trust my bookie I've been
rocking with him for over 10 years God
damn it and they're so easy to get your
money out of so easy to make money with
they got the best like simplest platform
to use the best props man trust me bet
anything anytime anywhere
with my bookie mybookie.ag promo code
bootleg sign up also shout out to our
family at hardean hardean Las Vegas Yes
you see him
I was just there in Vegas yesterday this
is the best place I've ever been to in
terms of dispensaries I've been to
probably hundreds of these things and
the experience at hardean is like
nowhere else
the customer service the selection of
Premium cannabis the experience as a
customer that you get when you walk into
the building in Las Vegas is a bar none
the best it's just the best man they are
the best we got so much going on this
weekend they're sponsoring the Rolling
Stone party on Friday Super Bowl weekend
fabulous Thursday offset Friday Meek
Saturday it's a lot going on with
Jardine you got to follow him at hardean
underscore Las Vegas right now shoot him
a follow on Instagram while you're at it
go to their website hardinglasvegas.com
so much fly gear so much fly weed what
are we talking about baby shout out to
hardine man that's the family man go if
you're in Vegas pull up on them man
Jardine Las Vegas okay
take me to your guys is like you guys
are at the crib what is the show you
guys binge watch on Netflix together
like are you guys like hanging out
watching TV like throwing on [__]
Breaking Bad or something
I don't know it's called
um
[Music]
the Wu-Tang show on Hulu yeah yeah
you like Wu-Tang Clan croshan is it with
that I don't know [__] about that oh
Davis is in it oh yeah I thought you was
talking about the lead one you don't
know the [__] about the real looking
things man
do you feel like uh
you're more focused on the TV [__] or
the music [__] right now because if you
guys put some real records together you
know you got you got everything else
going
I mean I have records I just been
dropping
not in a rush not in a rush what about
you blue because obviously you're a very
successful artist many plaques no more
like are you kind of off the music [__]
giggles
but I don't know I'm trying to find my
way in the background like got this
restaurant thing I'm about to try
[__] if that work out
I'll be in the bed every day what
happened to uh your restaurant in Santa
Clarita I saw it got vandalized oh yeah
I don't even know I ain't even gonna
cause it's been closed for a while right
yeah yeah I don't know why somebody
would want to vandalize an abandoned
building right
you know but we about to turn it into uh
the king of crabs I'm about to partner
up with them so you're gonna have like a
kind of the same type of vibe seafood
and [__] yeah it's gonna be seafood boil
more though like more hot with the bags
yeah yeah so you're kind of like off the
rap [__] low-key you're trying to make
all the all the all the other revenue
streams pop yeah yeah yeah I'm trying to
push her to do to fill in the blinks
like you know are you helping her with
like records because obviously you're
not an artist first right you decided to
kind of be artist after the fame is that
fair to say in terms of making music or
are you always making music
like were you making music prior to
meeting him
no we started like right when I met her
because I signed her as a musical artist
she wasn't really like even like
really [__] with music in no type of
way and I was like you should do it like
then we just started going crazy ever
since you helping it right sometimes
yeah
but she's more than likely she'll go in
there and just fill it up and then I
just fill in the blinks uh you can got
to link up with Gorilla how was that
conversation she's great that's got to
be a song y'all got to do record
and here we are she's cool I just be
having fun yeah I'll cook with that she
got some cool connection why it can't be
like that kid why you gotta be
interesting
but if she does a song with little baby
it's a big deal
it could change your career
and if she does this on the Glo really
could change her career but
at the cost of what expense some [__]
is not worth her doing a song No I okay
all things aside let's say let's not
even say a little baby let's say say
somebody else that's a break at the
expense of some [__] is not worth no
what does that mean what do you mean
what does that mean are you saying that
she would have to have sex with the
artist to get the feature
do you think is that what you're saying
you at some point yeah I don't think
that's the case with a lot of guys man
it's I don't know you that's why you
stay doing this thing and I stay doing
this thing all right because you you
clearly you don't know you don't know
nothing that's going on you don't know
nothing that's going on
I don't even do songs with females like
that
so like Drake I'm saying there's a lot
of unreleased songs between males and
females that had sex and these songs
never were released they were never what
I'm saying why weren't they released we
will never know
all right what is something that you've
learned from
being managed by whack and kind of
having like whack in your corner that
you are applying to your label and to
your management style
okay just
go all in with this [__] for real like
don't be afraid to be the bad guy or
look like you give a [__] just let that
[__] you know Let Her Shine for real
right it's all gonna work for her even
if
we go viral for the weirdest [__] it's
she's the woman I'ma look back
regardless she can slap the [__] out of
me right now
I would look bad right you gonna laugh
at me if I hit her back you gonna not
laugh at me and like be weird right
right but it's gonna go viral for her
regardless
are you guys like I was gonna say like
just in general with like the physical
[__] because it does feel like you guys
are
if from the outside looking in it feels
like an unhealthy relationship a toxic
relationship right like
um
do you think that a lot of that was
alcohol fueled like some of the [__] we
see online where you guys are like
really like scrapping you know what I'm
saying there's a lot of that alcohol
fueled or is it like
yeah sometimes we'd be sober
so I don't think do you think do you
think eventually that could be like a
situation because you know all it takes
is the wrong person to see something
somebody ends up in jail or we haven't
fought in a minute we don't do that just
work on not doing it right
[Music]
that's fair I mean if we gonna keep
doing it you know everything is is
business salvageable you know what I'm
saying right
we like just like we do the business we
gotta get along and you guys have this
TV show now that's like a smash exactly
like you know so it's like
is the TV show something that you feel
like you got a turn up on when it comes
to like when the cameras are around for
entertainment purposes to me nah I just
try to be honestly I like to joke a lot
so I'll just be funny goofy type she
sure I feel like that I feel like I'm
like that off camera but she I don't
know when the camera get on she's like
oh my gosh my jokes are not funny my
jokes are not funny on camera but on
camera
why are you joking like it's not funny
he knew my reaction that's what's the
funny part like no it's not funny
because I know your reaction obviously
you do no I really don't you surprised
me every time like she reacts different
to like
she's unpredictable
hey are you is it safe to say for Sean
you can deadlift more than your man I
just saw the video at Bradley Martin's
gym and it looked like
she got you yeah
see that's another female thing that
they're like you know what I'm saying
she'll get the best of that situation
because I lifted more than her you
lifted more she didn't even lift where
she lifted she almost lifted it
because I'm a man right she's a female
she didn't even finish the list
she's so strong she was close though you
could tell I just put it down I only put
it down because I didn't want to restore
in the morning I couldn't lift it well
because you're like a former athlete
right like what was like what's your
athletic background because we always
see these pictures that go viral of you
like back when you were in college or
you was like what all like athletically
did you used to do before you and then
played with this probably like trained
with them never really
fall through it like for the games and
stuff right I just started picking up on
this music [__] and it just
I don't know
but I could go back to it all right is
this all new new ink on your head yeah
how new is the uh
the cross is in the I don't feel like a
monorail
painful
yeah
any tattoos you regret yet
which ones
the one that's on my ankle with the
double ones oh devil horns
damn yeah shout out to you know shout
out to God
it's not divorce it is
what is it it is it's a Benjamin head
with a [__] Devils
what is horns what are those things with
you
cat ears they're not cat ears to [__]
you guys started uh kicking around any
ideas for any names for the kid
what names for the babies
hey what do you want you never answer
none of the questions
like that
it's like a female thing for real
if it's a boy you can't hear anyone you
can be a junior [__] Junior
blueface Jr blue face Jr
Jonathan Jonathan JR could I name my kid
blueface please don't please God don't
do not do that oh you have that okay I
think I would do that I think can we do
that
please say no blue face Porter
and he'll go up
okay she gonna do it for sure oh yeah
you cannot have no kid running around
here with their government name being
blueface that poor child
you could do it yeah it's done no it's
not
[__] I named you
your actual name is Christian yeah yes
that's not your fear you just added Rock
good job uh
did you end up ever
what you should do that
the blue facing don't do that bro I'm
gonna do it do not do that it's a bad
look uh I was gonna ask you oh royal
blue royal blue Royal's a dope name
hey Royal would be a hard name
I need a joke I was gonna name her after
Christian so it's a girl
if it was a girl I think you just told
us it's a girl
find out for sure on season two of Crazy
In Love
where she will
will find out that it's a girl she just
let that slip on accident no I just
want a girl Zeus Network download it on
your phone
how is the pay for doing a TV show with
Zeus is it solid like do they take care
of you guys because
Shawn you're kind of like carrying the
network you know what I mean like she is
on her back because you were on the
other [__] I carry everything I touched
on my back for sure
[Music]
this is true
um did you end up chopping it up with
Chris Brown at all off of Instagram when
you guys had your little back and forth
um
Regular internet [__] playing around
regular internet [__] just a regular day
for you yeah
I guess so
I mean [__] I didn't try to I Just Right
was that my fault yeah
yeah what's up with you and ddg [__] you
guys have like a whole [__] album
pretty much done right
[Music]
oh [__] I don't know
I ain't [__] I don't know I don't know
that [__] right now no idea doing this
[__] right here yo uh Krishan what
happened with that did Ruby Rose prop
you up like this all or did you prop
Ruby Rose up to send out all these
[__] screenshots
but you were you with her that day yeah
okay I'm talking to everybody what do
you mean I'm just curious were you like
yes screenshot that [__] and send it out
to the world [__] him girl did you say
that no I was like if it was me no okay
can you shut the [__] up among your
business
if it was you there would you tell her
if it was me I would like I would let
them all know that he tapped and he I
don't know but I'm like what would you
do she said I was already thinking about
it so you kind of pushed her over the
ledge you were like I wouldn't care I
don't care dude I don't have no
confirmation anything to whoever in the
message what
ddg's your friend that's what I would
make him your friend in some type of way
everybody my friend but it's like what
you mean everybody I can't control a
grown woman to do something [__]
you sound dumb as [__] um
are you friends with Ruby hey if I get
to blame my friends a lot of this I'm
you gonna like [__] shut the [__] up
you did it cause you wanted to do right
what the [__]
nope
what's the uh not if it was one of your
your friends that you would listen what
are you talking she was gonna do it me
with me there or with me they're not
there like what you mean the [__] you
just happened to be there she was giving
her like moral support was that the
crime scene yeah she didn't do anything
safe to say if you guys go on another
double date with ddg in his life
it'll just be weird what if you guys go
on a double date with uh with I don't
think that'll probably ever happen again
yeah probably not weird
I don't give a [__] yeah we know we know
that's that's the bad part that's the
bad part yeah I don't give a [__] I
don't think I don't think you guys are
gonna go to The Little Mermaid The
Little Mermaid Premiere you guys will
not be getting an invite too I don't
think so though it'll be all right hey
we gotta stop the interview to tell you
about our good Folks at Blue chew baby
that's right A lot of people keep asking
me does Bluetooth work [__] yeah it does
and if you don't believe me they'll give
you a whole month for free right now if
you go to bluetooth.com and use that
promo code bootleg that's bootry.com
promo code bootleg you get a month of
blue chew for free delivered to your
[__] house all you do is pay five
dollars in shipping what is blue tree
you ask well let me tell you it has same
active ingredient as Viagra and Cialis
in a chewable tablet but it is
discreetly delivered right to your
doorstep no awkward doctor's visits
imagine going and telling uh an old guy
about your dick
you would prefer not to do that I know
I'd prefer not to do that you know
but you could do it all online
bluetooth.com you don't have to go to
the doctor's appointment in person no
more no they're going to send it
straight to your door
all right your wife won't even know it
came your wife won't know that you came
and it came all right so what you do is
you uh you go to bluetooth.com use the
promo code bootleg and you get a month
of uh the whole thing for free that's
right a month supply of Bluetooth for
free straight to your door they also
just drop their new mint chewable which
is the same exact active ingredient as
Levitra so many options for you at
Bluetooth to make sure your dick is
right going into the springtime baby
look spring break's coming uh are you
gonna be coming
the real question is
is your partner going to be coming
not with the noodle dick
let's be honest make sure that shit's
hard as [__]
go to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg and get a month's supply for
free and if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction it's okay man
it happens to the best of us go to
Bluetooth and put a Band-Aid on that
thing bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
also
while we're talking about our partners
shout out to our family at Odd Socks oh
look at these Odd Socks underwear man
they're they're Half Baked
so much going on at Odd Socks uh so many
dope licenses man shout out to uh they
got Cheetos they got Jaws [__] Oreos
Cheech and Chong Naruto WWE by the way
WrestleMania is coming I can't wait to
see what dope WrestleMania socks they do
this year because last year they knocked
it out the parking odd Sox look the most
comfortable socks in the world they got
The Odd Socks Basics that you need on
your feet uh all you got to do is go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use the
promo code bootleg at checkout you'll
save 20 off your total order underwear
socks
[__] hats whatever you need they got it
at Odd Socks uh they just got the
Coca-Cola deal so you go get some
Coca-Cola drawers Coca-Cola socks so
much always going on in Odd Socks I'm
gonna always say my favorites are the
WWE in the Breaking Bad Ones
um so go to oddsocksofficial.com right
now use that promo code bootleg and you
will save 20 off at checkout shout out
to them most comfortable socks in the
world crazy comfortable underwear my
goodness if you ain't got Odd Socks on
your feet and ass what are you doing out
in these streets all right go to
hotsocksofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off let's get back to the
interview what's uh so what's next oh
you're talking about you're acting like
I really did something like Krishan
curious what's like what's next with the
music [__] like what's coming down the
pipeline besides season two of the TV
show what's what do you all got
huh what do you got coming in next songs
yeah a baby season two of the show
any uh any any other like we know he's
got a restaurant do you have any
entrepreneurial stuff going on on the
side that you wanna merch the merch
yeah is the merch out
huh does the merch out not yet coming
soon
when's the next music dropping
I mean I guess you're the label right so
when she's dropping some new music
[Music]
yeah I mean I usually let her decide you
know choose on which what she want to go
with it don't give a [__] that much and
then I just put all the strings together
so you're not it's safe to say you're
not passionate about music
it's not that it's just
or passionate about like I come up with
the dates and dates
right no you just gotta pick one and
say like how you want it to be
what about movies Krishan I feel like
you would be a great she's a good actor
I feel like you could be in some movies
she's a hell of an actor
boy I tell you Kev I feel like there's a
lot she's good right now there's a lot
she's stabbing the table with the knife
can you be quiet
hmm they say one good thing you turn
into
something wrong with you no I'm serious
clapping way too hard over there you
stabbing the table a little too hard
over there oh man you're making me worry
about that that's uh I'm not ready stop
playing with me
stay over there what is you doing what
would you guys say
is like what's the last date y'all went
on that was like not
you know do you guys go on dates are we
are we hitting the [__] bowling alley
are we going to dinner like like what's
quality time with y'all two like
quality time
well Utah
you want to get that one I'm always
getting there why won't you answer any
other questions you don't answer all the
questions
um quality time yeah we go bowling I
like the bowl
uh that's not quality time we go eat you
do that with anybody well what's quality
time Krishan
that's what she is
are you at least writing your name on
the table as you stab it because at
least then if someone's like yo what
happened to the table here I'd be like
just read what it says right Christian
rock was here
um no but what's quality time with y'all
Christian what do y'all like y'all going
to uh goddamn dinner is it walks on the
beach
yeah
uh working out I don't know I'll
probably just at home for real at the
crib you guys live together yeah
nice
what what's up with you good what's up
with you why are you feeling weird
oh look at you guys see y'all get along
bro
how long has has because obviously
we're gonna [__] end up with with a
just a carved up wooden table
uh well listen man
season two when is that dropping do we
know
uh probably like the summer December the
summer the summer okay coming soon would
you do any spin-off shows obviously this
is kind of like a spin-off on Zeus
because she was on the other show
and so I'm like Wu-Tang
I'd like to do some little girls club
[__] like some where no he's not
that's some Incorporated so blue Girls
Club is coming against
so you're not allowed to no that's what
I'm breaking up with him he's just weird
how many times have y'all broken up
you're always trying not to include me
and [__]
you say that now and that's not the case
you said that before because you did it
before
said it before
that's her manager do you think I should
have her on Blue Girls Club our only
fans in season four why is she doing the
whole Zeus and the crazy in love
are you still doing the only fan [__] no
I just kind of like shut up decided like
to go to the next yeah Zeus is bigger
than that right
yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure the only
fans yeah did you say he's single
would you guys say that you guys are on
and off a lot
these whatever you want to do whatever
I'm on all the time she's off she's on
enough why are you lying
why are you lying
[Music]
oh my
god well listen I think you guys I have
always you know I always tell people
blue I think you're a smart guy
Krishan I think that you have to uh
understand that you have like a level of
stardom right now that is very rare and
I think that y'all gotta you know clean
this [__] up a little
I'm just like I don't want nobody going
to jail I don't want you know I've never
been to jail since the last time I've
been in jail
well tonight when was that I think
Valentine's Day the last Valentine's Day
so it's been over a year yeah it's been
a minute oh that easy part but like I
was probably like six seven eight months
ago right well let's try this yeah you
was in Phoenix I remember seeing it
let's try to stay out of jail we got a
kid on the way I know
do you think motherhood is going to
change you Christian
good
I don't know like what the [__] I'm
nothing I'm fine
you you hope so I'm fine I'm fine
you need to change
is it safe to say everyone needs to
change everyone should be self-improving
at all times in the world right if you
ain't getting okay so why y'all gotta
talk about me
I mean I didn't say that I just said do
you think I mean fatherhood motherhood
changes people so you know
me uh started planning for the future a
little bit more
than I used to um
well look I just want y'all to like
be safe be healthy
a little less toxic you guys have a lot
of dope [__] going on
Christian if you I think if you took the
music [__] real serious it'd be crazy
for you you know what I mean I think you
would go up I think you need to start
working with some writers some dope
producers
and or if you don't want it who gives a
[__] you know
you know the reality TV [__] is cool but
it's got an expiration date you know
what I mean the music [__] the you just
gotta sit back and watch my boy all
right I mean we always cross brand new
like on our show like right we um we
like executive producers so we got more
like say so as far as the music in the
background right
so how's the novel coming up we always
get to encourage the [__] huh what do we
got over there just your name no
no it's forever oh
Jonathan that blue face
how many Jonathan related tattoos do we
have now
Savory I know right she said I just have
seven I do that's I'm stopping
when did you realize
that
because the last time we did an
interview was like right after when and
I'm still well I was still giving it was
like a year and a half ago it was like
right after the whole G-Wagon [__]
popped off right right and and you drove
the G wagon across the country
and so I was like it looked like oh well
[__] this is a bad situation when did
you kind of come to the realization that
man this girl's literally crazy in love
for me and we need to like you know
explore
our relationships
huh he was mad but he missed me that's
what happened
like when and then he missed me
we didn't know he was gonna get over it
that's not what he asked go ahead no I
mean like what happened
we didn't really get back together we
just started missing me I was gonna say
like when did you realize like
this she's the one I'm gonna be with
she's the one I'm gonna you know
interviews in Chicago
I think it was like
like last summer
like literally like recently April and
what were you when you first saw the
this tattoo blue it's a thing right
there you know that's a that's a real
sign of love
what was your reaction
you give a [__] about it did you it was
right yeah I thought I thought it was a
dope [__] I thought [__]
your Christian face tattoos coming soon
is that two type of person you literally
have Benjamin Franklin's face tattooed
on your body twice I'm looking at both
of them right now
twice why are you trying to believe me
like that kid that's crazy
just say for real be for real yeah
that's crazy you're like I wouldn't get
Noah's face tattooed on my body except
an old white man who died 200 years ago
oh by the way twin is [__] Mike
well listen man I'm excited for y'all to
uh step into uh Parenthood together
what
is
it why don't you give me because you
don't deserve one
look what you didn't do listen remember
everything's about the kid you guys got
my little rock rock man you guys got a
[__] this whole video you guys got a
baby on the way so I'm excited for y'all
to be uh obviously parents to a new kid
oh yeah
hooray when is the due date do we know
none your damn business all right well
shout out to Christian rock and blueface
season two of Crazy In Love summertime
baby soon music soon I'm high bro don't
take this interview too serious it's all
good man appreciate y'all pulling up
Krishan thank you for not breaking
anything except
the table I'll take that yeah that's
good that's like a message that actually
this table's gonna be worth a million
dollars yep I had an auction there it is
we're gonna frame it right if we ever
get rid of the table we're gonna cut
that square out and put it on the wall
thanks for coming through though
boom